[MUSIC]
Eric, it is an honor to have you
here today welcome back to the GSB.
>> Thank you, I'm very,
very excited to be back every time.
>> [APPLAUSE] >> Now I'd like to
start off by thanking you for
not only helping to keep the world
connected during the pandemic but
for creating a product that brought
all of us a lot of joy,
and laughs too.
Everything from Zoom weddings
to Zoom attire,
I'm thinking professional tops and
pajama bottoms, and everything in
between so, thank you.
>> That's why I like Stanford GSB
because I know Stanford GSB
only use Zoom never use any other
product.
>> [LAUGH] >> That is a true
statement.
Now few founders can say that their
companies have turned into
a global verb.
Take us back to the very beginning.
How did you first come up with
the idea for Zoom?
>> Back into 2010 timeframe I was
at Cisco, I was Corporate Vice
President over there.
When I came to America in 1997,
I joined WebEx as one of the first
recevoir founding engineers.
I work as extremely hard try to
make WebEx better,
unfortunately after 10 years,
11 years hard work back to 2010
timeframe every time I can tell you
my talk with the customer I didn't
see a single heavy customer.
Every morning I woke up I did not
want go to office.
because when you talk to
the customer,
text the customer everytime,
share their pinpoint, the mission,
we do quality not a very good,
mobile experience horrible, I
really wanted to fix that problem.
Unfortunately, they told me that
that's not a good idea you still
can sell a lot of WebEx why do
you want to cannibalize WebEx.
And it took me one year I failed to
convince others.
I guess I should have come to GSB
learn how to convince others, so
I guess I did not take that course
I failed to convince others.
But anyway so finally I decided to
leave to build my own solution.
>> And a key part in your story you
mentioned coming to the United
States in the late 1990s.
That path to get to the US wasn't
necessarily smooth was it.
What kind of challenges did you run
into coming to Silicon Valley?
>> That's a long time ago.
I thought it was pretty
straightforward I was very good
engineer I should have get a visa
unfortunately it
took me nine attempts to get here.
My visa application got rejected
eight times.
But luckily, I got the final visa
and came here but
looking back I really appreciate
because the reason why is more like
to practice my perseverance, right?
And again took me one and
a half years to come to America to
pursue my American dream, so.
>> Wow, and keeping on the
international fame, I don't know if
you know but we have quite a few of
our classmates in the audience who
are internationals, and are living
in the US for the first time.
What were some of those first years
like in the US as someone who had
never lived in Silicon Valley or
the United States before?
>> That's a good question.
I would say back to 1997, and
I remember before, I came here,
I was extremely excited, right?
because when I was a kid,
always read the stories of HP,
and Silicon Valley,
Apple very exciting.
However, after I landed here I
realize is not that easy because
you have to learn the culture,
history, how to make new friends,
build trust, language barrier,
all kinds of things.
Luckily I live in Silicon Valley,
in Silicon Valley not only
the worldwide innovation center but
also the people here are extremely
friendly.
A lot of leaders they would like to
help you.
I think after several months,
I feel like already part of
the Silicon Valley and
looking back I was wow,
this is the best experience.
>> And I love your optimism.
You came from China
to the United States, not speaking
English applied for a visa nine
times, rose up in WebEx and Cisco,
and then you came to the Stanford
Graduate School of Business.
What role did being at the GSB play
in that vision to turn an idea you
had back in 1997 into a company
that is now known around the world.
>> That's a good questions.
Anytime if I have time I take
a break I want to be part of GSB
group.
I want to sit here like you guys I
think very excited.
The reason why I said so is back to
early time before I came here,
I was very confident in wow,
America huge opportunity as long as
you work hard,
you can achieve your dream.
I worked for WebEx for awhile,
quite often I've worked very,
very hard and
made very good progress.
However sometimes your confidence
level is suddenly not as high as
the first day when you landed here
and because you makes some progress
you do not want to take risks you
do not want to start over, right?
And back to 2006 I participated
the Stanford and
the GSB SEP program.
I can tell you actually just
literally after the summer,
the day after I left Stanford,
I felt more like the first day when
I landed in San Francisco Airport.
My confidence level I was extremely
high, I almost quit a job into
starting a new company at the time.
But anyway being here just one
summer my confidence level is at
least twice high for all the GSB
students you're here 2 years I
guarantee you you're confidence
level probably four times or five.
If you're not, I can tell you back
on program SEP program also pretty
good too.
But anyway, I was so grateful to
Stanford GSB integrated curriculum,
right, all of case studies, and
greater professors, and yeah.
By the way, after that,
every time to manage a company,
manage a team is pretty challenging
and sometimes you feel like very
lonely or down time.
Every time I feel like that
if I come back to GSB and
to Stanford Campus I can tell
you I sort of fully recharge myself
that's another reason why I'm here
today I need to fully recharge
myself so yeah.
>> It's definitely a special place
I agree with you.
>> Very special and
also not to mention entrepreneurial
atmosphere here in GSB.
I think a great opportunity,
I think, for
all of you after you graduate.
>> Well, fast for that company that
you had the idea for way back when
you were inspired at the GSB, that
company has fundamentally changed
the way that we all stay connected.
>> That's what GSB taught us,
right?
>> [LAUGH] >> To build something to
change the world.
>> Absolutely, but
Zoom is seen as something that was
an overnight success but
that wasn't the case, was it?
>> Yeah, it too cost many managers
effort, I think prior to
Covid probably most of the people
never heard about Zoom.
But we were very patient as long as
we keep improving the product
experience to make sure our
customer happy,
I know sooner or later,
we are going to achieve something.
>> And so it sounds like a lot of
hard work, went into it and
part of that hard work was finding
investors for Zoom.
It's hard to fathom but,
back then investors weren't jumping
at the bit to invest in Zoom.
What lessons do you have from that
period of time that you can
share with the entrepreneurs and
the aspiring entrepreneurs in
the audience today?
>> Is good to know we sit here, so
I can share the story.
So And after I left the Cisco,
I thought I was Vice President of
Engineering, I view the web bugs.
I have also a lot of connections,
it should be
straightforward, right?
Talking to me since they all want
to invest you, that's my thought.
But I was completely wrong, and I
try to talk almost every VC I knew,
nobody want to invest in me.
And plus some other VC
friend told me that Eric,
as long as you do something else,
out check was ready for you.
So meaning you should now
build another
video collaboration solution.
And I remember I told you that when
we see and again the VC mission
that's a horrible idea,
you should not do that.
But on the way back and
I told myself, you are wrong,
I gotta prove you're wrong.
So after that begged office,
I changed the screensaver to be you
are wrong.
>> [LAUGH] >> And
I remember that after we became on
NASDAQ a public company.
So actually when you try to raise
the capital, right?
For sure we are humble, right?
There's a reason why VC
did not invest you, right?
You got to understand why it's good
for you, right?
But sometimes, and
VCs might be wrong,
if you think you're right and
VCs are wrong,
it's not a bad thing, right?
It give you more reasons you got to
work harder to prove they're wrong,
that's what had happened to us.
>> I think that's
an incredibly important lesson that
I know a lot of us starting
companies will keep in mind.
>> Yeah, don't give up, yeah, yeah.
>> Absolutely. >> Often,
VC will not be right,
especially for those VCs who never
got educated here at GSB, right?
>> [LAUGH] >> And
I think another important lesson in
that story is learning to pivot.
As you mentioned Zoom was
a successful company before
the pandemic,
serving mainly B2B clients.
And then boom,
the pandemic happens, and you have
to add B2C into that portfolio.
What were some of the big lessons
that came away and
how did you rapidly adjust to such
a significant expansion in your
customer base?
>> Yeah, I think that's a tough
experience because you're so right,
Zoom was built to serve for
enterprise customer prior to
pandemic crisis.
And during a pandemic crisis, and
we had so many new users,
consumers all kinds of new use
cases like a K to 12 schools or
telemedicine, telehealth.
We never thought about those
consumer use cases.
And the mistake we made is, prior
to COVID crisis we had a lot of
security features, but normally we
work together with enterprise ITT.
They are going to test our
product with some QC process.
They are going to enable some
security features or
privacy features.
And horror for
those first time consumers
experience is very different.
They do not have ITT, right?
Then we realize we made a huge
mistake.
Not only did we play the role of
offering the service, but
also we should have played a role
of serving the IT for long.
And so we'll learn a hard lesson,
we quickly took actions and
we want to trust the back.
Because when you sort of lost your
trust, you got to make sure take
actions as crooked as possible.
And also keep everything open and
transparent.
Why you made a mistake?
What's the effort, right?
How to fix all those problems?
Keep everything open, transparent
to communicate with the customers,
that's a lesson learned and
finally we win the trust back
>> Absolutely,
and I want to pick up on a word you
said, which is mistake.
Something that I admire so
much about you as a leader is your
honesty and transparency like you
were talking about.
And for example, when you're data
and security issues were brought up
during the pandemic, your response
was to publicly roll out
a statement of how we're fixing it.
Here are the problems that we see,
and this is how we're going to take
feedback into account.
You touched on this a little bit,
but would love to dive in
a bit more.
How do you see transparency
being important in leadership?
And how can we as future leaders,
and leaders in the business world
think about being transparent in
difficult situations?
I think first of all during
the difficult situation,
you got to take a step back, right?
Try to understand what had
happened, right?
Those end users, why need to share
with you all those issues,
because I think they care about us.
Ultimately, for us if
we can address all those problems,
who is going to benefit?
Zoom, right?
Ourselves, that's why we embrace
all those challenges, right?
And at the same time we go to and
take actions, right?
First of all, I needed to publicly
tell them sorry, I mess up.
We got to do fix for
all the issues we know, what's
the problem, what's root cause,
what's a pass and a solution to
address all those issues, right?
And I personally hosted
a weekly in a security meetings and
with all the end users and also
share with them transparently about
those efforts, plans, programs,
how we double down on security and
privacy, a lot of things, right?
Any user they're pretty smart,
they understand, are you going
to try hard to fix those issues or
do you just talk about that, right?
So that's in the what will be
everyday, two years ago at Zoom and
prior to COVID crisis,
look at our privacy security,
very small, around a dozen people.
And now we have more than 200 full
time employees, right?
And because of that,
we took privacy and security very,
very seriously because a lot of
security companies,
they deploy Zoom, Garmin customers
who use Zoom, and finally,
the customers really like Zoom.
And saying, yeah, you guys admitted
those mistakes and
quickly fix that problem.
And also make it better, even
better than any of our competitors
in terms of security and privacy.
>> because you had a lot of
people relying on you, can I get
a show of hands, how many people
used Zoom during the pandemic?
I think I know the answer,
but- >> Thank you, I use it too.
>> [LAUGH] >> Yeah, there we go,
John G Levin mentioned this
stuff before,
but I want to bring it out again
because I think it's incredible.
The number of Zoom users increased
from 10 million to 300 million
per day.
>> Sorry,
that's meeting participants.
>> Yes, meeting participants, yes,
meeting participants per day in
just four months.
I mean, Zoom was really
pushed into the spotlight and
also given a chance to shine.
Walk us through your thought
process, when did you realize that
Zoom could play a critical role
during the pandemic?
>> I think of course, and
I remember I think the first time
in my thought in school and also
include the school of an online.
I remember it's a Monday morning,
the first time I worked so hard and
my daughter even don't know what I
was doing.
But as she asked me the first time,
hey, dad how to raise my
hand during the Zoom call?
I realized wow,
I never thought about my kids they
are going to use Zoom.
And I think the first time I think
I realized, wow,
this is a huge potential.
And they didn't realize it, and
there's a huge opportunity,
to guide them how to and
help the world,
how to help the community and
the society, right?
This is a responsibility on our
shoulders, right?
The good news we heavily invested
in our company culture, the team
brokerage worked extremely hard.
I can tell you I personally had way
more syllables nice than any time
in my career.
And along with
a lot of engineers because we need
the added capacity in India,
Brazil, a lot of other countries,
quite often maybe this small
glitches you got to fix quickly.
I can tell you wow,
that's six months time frame and
the good news was it's pretty
tough, very challenging.
Can't even imagine.
I have to ask hearing about
the responsibility, hearing about
all the things you were thinking
about the sleepless nights.
How do you stay grounded and how do
you prioritize what really matters?
>> That's why I like GSB.
I learned a lot of stuff I was
already mentally prepared well,
right?
Because on one hand if you really
want to do something to make the
world better, to change the world,
for sure, you are going to face all
kinds of challenges, right?
Mentally you got to prepare well,
meaning may not be today,
maybe next year,
maybe next week, right?
So, mentally at least I was
prepared very well.
So when that happens and
I realized on the one hand,
you're facing the challenge and
on the other hand also I realized,
if you can overcome all those
challenges, right?
Guess what?
Your company, your team, yourself
will become very different,
become much better, right?
That's why we level that
opportunity, look at every corners
of our business.
What we can do differently to
improve our inner team size for
example, prior to COVID we're
going to have a little bit of over
2000 employees.
For now actually we hired over 6000
employees over the past 18 months,
right?
And to make sure for the scale our
business this is a great
opportunity for us for the future.
And then to position us very well,
to transform our business from
being a videoconferencing killer
app company to be a platform
business.
That's huge opportunity.
>> And the opportunities that Zoom
has even in the future are huge.
I want to come to a question first
though, that is something that we
talk a lot about here at the GSB,
which is work life balance.
I've heard that you are in addition
to running one of the biggest
companies, also an active parent on
your children's basketball teams.
How do you balance and
how do you think about that work
life balance between spending time
on your company while also spending
time with your family?
>> Yeah, that's one thing I guess
during my time in GSB, I didn't
learn how to balance that and
the reason why at that time I also
thought of a balance.
And I talked with many other
classmates and some professors
tried to figure out a way how
to balance and later on realized as
long as you think about balance,
there's no answer.
So meaning don't listen my balance.
Think about if you like work and
it's part of a life, you're
passionate about something and
especially you're good at something
and you also can create a value.
And if you like that,
that's a part of life, and
work is life, life is work.
Listen my balance that's.
Two is, what if there's a conflict
between work and life?
At Zoom and
our principle is very simple,
whenever there's a conflict between
work and life, your family first,
always like that.
Take my personal experience for
example, many years ago and
I think that's our Christmas party.
And my son's high school they're
going to have a basketball game.
And is in San Francisco,
I told our team, Sorry,
there's a conflict.
I'm going to enjoy my son's
basketball game.
I will be very late to
the Christmas party, right?
That's our philosophy.
Don't see my balance,
finding your passion.
Work is life, life is work,
at the same time,
if there's a conflict,
family first.
That's very simple.
But doing single balance.
If you single balance every day,
you are going to struggle.
Every month you are going to
struggle, yeah.
>> In addition to putting family
first, it sounds like happiness
is something that is so
important to you.
How do you take that personal value
of happiness and then translate
into a company culture that's also
based on happiness?
>> Yeah, so company culture is
extremely important and looking
back I think that that's one thing
I personally feel proud of.
Because on the first day when I
started Zoom,
I remember only two things I wrote
on company culture and value.
And it was the border use
the furniture, buy two for a table.
But anyway, so our company culture,
just two words.
Very easy, right?
Very catchy.
Deliver happiness and meaning.
And for me, as a CEO of a company
my number one priority.
Is to make sure Zoom employee
are happy.
I believe if you have happy
employees, you are going to have
happy customers, right?
So I do all I can to think about
how to make sure Zoom
employee happy,
and at the same time employee they
are going to make a customer happy.
That's our company culture.
>> Wow, and it sounds like as CEO
you have a lot of people to keep
happy your customers,
your employers, shareholders.
What happens when one of these
stakeholder groups isn't happy?
How do you keep them on board?
>> So first of all, we should tell
them why was the purpose of life,
right?
The purpose of life is really about
happiness, right?
And also the sustainable happiness
comes from making others happy
right?
And for those shareholders, right?
Like a stock price is down they're
not happy with tell them, Hey, this
is more short term thing, right?
And a plus and
we should have communicate with
them very well about why let's say,
you want to buy Zoom stock.
Why you become a stakeholder,
right?
And ultimately we want to make sure
the employees or
shareholders and retool and extend
our company innovation, right?
When you look at it the short term
stuff, right?
And if we do not understand
the purpose of life is just focus
on the short term happiness, right?
For sure that's not our
company the culture.
We always think about what you can
do differently to focus on long
term sustainable happiness, right?
Rather than just the short term
happiness.
Sometimes employee is just
to focus on the money or
the power or the title.
Those are the short term happiness.
Longer term why you got to look
at make sure that
the happiness is sustainable.
Always and in the long run,
make a customer happy, make employ
happy and down the road I think
you will get a much better return.
>> And keeping on that happiness
thing because I think it's so
unique to who you are as a person.
Something else that we think a lot
about here at the GSB is what
kind of leader we want to become.
We have a class where we
ask ourselves,
why would someone follow us?
Given your background
being an immigrant to the US being
an engineer, overcoming adversity,
putting happiness at the center of
everything, how would you describe
your leadership style.
And how has that evolved over
the years?
I think of my leadership style for
sure again, and
I was very fortunate to live in
Valley and
I've been doing my career here,
had so many mentors.
Truly helped me,
shaped my leadership style and
I think many years ago, I will say
my leadership style is more
like a very hands on leader, right?
And I tried to work so
hard trying to understand, again,
this is kind of should have come
a gap first otherwise,
I'm not going to spend so
much time to learn marketing,
sales and support and the strategy.
And I learned a lot because I
really wanted to understand how
business operates, right?
And it's more a very hands on
leadership.
That's kind of my personal
style and but later on I realized
that's not a scalable, right?
How to delegate some of the burden
pointed works to a team,
how to make sure you are surrounded
by a lot of leaders, probably
they're even better than you.
I think I learned a lot otherwise,
especially over the past two
years and
I do not think I can sleep, right?
Why they've given us so
many challenges, so
many opportunities, right?
That's my leadership style I
think completely changed, right?
How to balance between the hands on
leadership and also the dedication.
So it sounds like as Zoom scaled,
you had to adapt your leadership
style to fit that so
it could scale with it.
>> Yeah, otherwise there's no way
to scale up your business.
>> Exactly, we talked about Zoom
pre-pandemic, we talked about Zoom
during the pandemic.
Let's look to the future.
In five years from now what is
Zoom going to look like and
what are you excited for?
>> Five years later,
Zoom will be for
sure five years better, and so
[LAUGH] after five years.
But anyway, I think from our
perspective we truly believe and
in the future from a technology
perspective, Zoom can deliver
a much better experience than
face-to-face meeting.
You can sit at home,
I can sit anywhere,
let's say local Starbucks coffee,
I shake your hands,
you feel my hands shaking,
I give a hug, you feel my intimacy.
And even if we speak a different
language, we can understand each
other and you get a cup of coffee,
I can enjoy the smell remotely.
All those technologies will be part
of our offering in the future.
At the same time,
we would like to transform our
business to be a platform company.
Video, voice, team chat,
conference room systems,
events webinar, and also all other
collaboration solutions.
Essentially, the end user, they can
live within the Zoom platform,
can get most of the work done,
rather than always switching back
and forth to other applications.
The switching cost is very
high, right?
Essentially, Zoom more like
a hybrid work operating system.
That's why we are very excited.
>> I'm excited for that, too.
>> If any of you like that vision,
feel free to join us, yeah.
>> [LAUGH] >> So you kept the world
connected during a global pandemic
and brought happiness to millions.
10, 20,
even 50 years from now, what do you
want people to remember about you,
and about Zoom?
>> It's good questions.
I think one thing I really want
Zoom and
myself to be remembered is that, if
someone write a book, they will say
during the 2020 COVID-19 crisis,
there's a company called Zoom.
Truly helped the world,
truly enabled global connections.
That's what I want the world to
remember myself and also the Zoom,
also all the Zoomies,
and yeah, that's pretty much.
But again, and we just started our
chapter two and we are embarking on
Zoom 2.0 journey, some more
exciting stuff down the road, yeah.
>> Wow, principled and
purposeful leadership,
you must be a GSB alum.
>> Yeah, absolutely, yeah.
>> So, a final question before you,
before we move into audience Q&A.
This is a question we'll be asking
each of our speakers as they
come throughout the year.
And the question is,
principled leadership is paramount
at the Stanford GSB.
What do you view as your role in
leading with responsibility to not
only your company but
to society at large?
>> Yes, it's good question.
So, one thing like Cisco and
when I was there, the Cisco former
CEO Chairman John Chambers is such
a greater leader.
I learned a lesson from him.
As a leader, right, when you look
at the business and organization
you work for, don't always think
about your organization.
Always think about your
organization's social
responsibility, what you can do to
help the community and
society, right?
That's what I learned, that's why
when it comes to Zoom's value,
our company value, just one word,
care, they care about
the community, customer, company,
teammates, as well as ourselves.
To care about community,
that's extremely important.
Make sure your business,
your organization,
is part of a society.
You think about how you
can play differently, right?
Not only think about day-to-day
work, but also play a bigger role.
Make sure you can contribute back
to the community, to the society.
>> Spoken as a true GSB alum,
[LAUGH].
>> Thank you.
>> We are now going to move- >> I
have a positive test, right,
to be a very qualified GSB alum.
>> 100% >> Thank you.
>> Passed with flying colors.
>> Thank you.
>> We're now going to move into
audience Q&A.
>> I still remember that particular
day, October 27, 2020, when I was
in China, having a Zoom interview
with Harvard Business School, and
right in the middle of
the interview, >> [LAUGH] >> No,
the severe connection issue or
censorship that might have captured
my twisted sense of humor,
whatever it was, forcibly shut me
out of the meeting and
never allow me to log back in.
And a month later,
I received a rejection letter
from Harvard Business School.
>> [LAUGH] >> Which spurred me to
apply for the even better business
school, Stanford GSB, where I
proudly find myself at this moment.
And I really appreciate Zoom for
having changed my path in a very
meaningful way.
>> [LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE] >> Anyway, so regardless
of the countless efforts made by
Zoom to improve the security and
transparencies, I think there
are still not a few people who have
concerns over Zoom's association
with Chinese government.
And in fact some organizations
including the Taiwanese government,
Japanese government, and
some private company in the US
still banned official use of Zoom.
In my view, that Zoom has been
particularly susceptible to this
kind of China-related speculations.
Because of your personal background
and the fact that Zoom was actually
complicit in China's censorship and
repression in 2020.
So my question is, how would you go
about reconciling your personal
identity as a former Chinese
national holding American passport?
What's the need for navigating
multinational tech company like
Zoom in such complex and sensitive
business environments shaped by the
US-China relationship these days?
>> Yeah, good question.
First of all, I think that's one of
the best use cases, right,
experience about Zoom.
So how lucky you are,
you are part of GSB.
>> [LAUGH] >> And
I think it boils down to one thing,
right?
How to build trust, right?
This is very important,
all those issues you just described
boils down to one thing.
Because the other side, see
the customers who never use Zoom
because of some other government.
They do not know who we are, right,
how to establish that trust, right?
That's why at Zoom, the Speed of
Trust is our favorite book, right?
The problem you mentioned, yeah,
I was born in China, right?
When pandemic crisis came, a lot of
us is in the corner of Zoom for
some mission-critical application.
They do not know who I am, right?
And I'm American citizen, right?
They do not know that.
They say, Zoom is, maybe it's kind
of registered in other countries.
That's not the case, right?
All those issues, guess what?
We did not do a good job.
We should proactively communicate
with the world.
Who is Zoom, what kind of
the company that Zoom is?
And also what's our company,
the culture, and the value, and
mission, all these kind of things.
We lever that opportunity, right,
to communicate with whoever may not
understand our business,
may not understand our team,
may not know me, right?
We lever that opportunity to
build trust.
That's why today, you look
at President Zelenskyy, right?
He's using Zoom, right?
And also a lot of government
that also use Zoom as well, right?
By so many security companies
as well.
Ultimately, that's a way for
you to always take a step back to
understand what had happened.
And then understanding their
problem, the root cause and
if there is a good solution.
I think that's why today we're
doing pretty well on that front.
>> I just want to maybe ask you how
you share your secrets,
to be such a big
success as a minority of the Asian?
And today we also have a lot of
international student,
Asian student here, do you want to
share how to make such a big impact
as a minority in the United States,
and please share some advice and
experience?
>> I think it's good question.
First of all, I think again,
sitting well in America, right,
cultural wise is where I will say
is open minded.
As long as you work hard and
contribute, right?
And I think they will embrace you,
right?
The community and
also the business industry,
I think that's a huge opportunity,
right?
I think don't think about
your background that much,
just think about what you can do,
right, to contribute back to
the community, to society, right?
If you can show the world,
you can create a lot of value,
here you will be very successful.
Quite often the reason why it's
not successful, because don't think
about from other's perspective,
always think about what you can do
differently.
Everyday you become
better version of yourself,
you completely get better, and
also you make the world better.
And then actually you'll be
recognized wherever, your business
also will be successful.
Ultimately, I think the common
mistake is because you do not get
better, your business do not get
better and you think about,
maybe actually you're a minority.
And also there's some
discrimination.
I think that's not root cause,
right?
Root cause always focus on
yourself, focus on your business,
and create more value to
the society, that's the key.
>> My name is Jowin Ting,
I am a second year here.
My question is about the role
mentorship has played in your life
and your career development.
Can you tell us who your most
influential mentor was and
how they shaped your life?
>> Wow, we do not have a lot of
time, otherwise I can
share a lot of mentors.
So, and I think one of the,
let me take a step back, right?
So one of the leaders I truly think
influenced me most in terms of
leadership style is the former
CEO of Walmart, H Lee Scott, right?
He talked about leadership and
Cisco upside, has a huge influence.
I even wrote a blog and so had
a poster on the wall in my office.
And I think he is for
sure is the best in terms of
influence to my leadership style.
And also
over the past several years,
quite often see some progress and
while I was facing challenges,
I can call all of the CEOs,
like Salesforce CEO Mark, and
Oracle CEO Larry, and
HP CEO Enrique, and also Ray Dalio,
and he's such a great leader.
He and his team is stop
by near my office to talk with our
leadership team, help us a lot.
Yeah, quite often I can call
many CEOs, right?
And it will help our business.
That's one the reason why Silicon
Valley has a great culture a lot of
leaders, they want to help you out.
Actually you got to
proactively reach out to them,
I pretty sure a lot of leaders,
even if they do not know you,
they want to help you out, right?
Because it's how to give back, this
is part of Silicon Valley culture.
>> It's Alex, I'm an MBA too.
So at the beginning of
the pandemic, there are obviously
a lot of video chatting services
out there, Google+ and Skype and,
of course, Zoom.
And why was it Zoom the one that
triumphed in the end?
>> Good question.
I think the founder is a GSB
alumni, that's the reason.
>> [LAUGH] >> Yeah,
that's really cool,
that's a reason.
>> [LAUGH] >> But anyway,
I think to build a better solution,
you got to spend more time with
your customers,
ultimately what's innovation?
Innovation read about you want to
be the first company to understand
customer pain point, and also take
actions quickly and it will be the
first window to build a solution.
If you keep doing that, sooner or
later you are going to win.
So that's our approach.
That's the reason other
competitors, I think,
they lost, yeah.
>> My name is Yu Chen Zhou and
I'm a first year MBA student here.
My question is what was
the most frustrating moment in your
professional career and how did you
overcome the difficulties and
what did you learn from it?
>> That's great question.
So I think, again, there's too many
frustration moments in my career.
Very often in the past,
however, as a number one thing,
you got to calm down, that's very,
very important.
Because to be a CEO, the most
important thing is you want to make
a better decision, right?
If you do not calm down and
if you're very frustrated,
very likely you're going to make
a wrong decision.
That's very important, you got to
make sure, take step back,
calm down, make sure you always try
to make a better decision,
that's number one thing.
Number two thing is,
at Zoom, we also have a formula.
The problem, root cause, solution.
Frustration will not have you
anything, right?
Every time you see the problem,
right, and huge problem, right,
you've probably feel frustrated.
You got to take a step back,
just focus on problem, root cause,
and solution.
And you think about,
if you can have a better solution,
guess what?
You are going to become better
company.
And every time you think, wow,
because there's a problem, Zoom
will get better tomorrow, I'm going
to become better leader tomorrow.
Then you should be happier, right?
Why you feel frustrated?
And that's my principal
>> I'm Eb Shetta, an MBA too,
you talked about the importance of
patience as you were building Zoom
and that it took time.
But now that you're a listed
company, there's also share price
pressures, there's pressures of
quarterly results.
So how do you balance the short
term share price responsibility
that you have versus the long term
customer pain point view?
>> That's a really good question.
I think that one, yeah,
this is another mentor,
my mentor also.
And I learn a lot from him as well.
The company called Nvidia, right?
And by the founder and CEO, Jason,
also the Stanford alum as well.
See, all the student alumni
accomplishment very well, so.
You look at Nvidia,
the company history.
I remember there's a time,
ten years in a row,
the stock price was flat.
Look at it today, number one
semiconductor company, because make
sure as a leader, right, always
focus on long term goal, right?
Do not focus on short term, and
also you got to add a good team,
communicate with the team.
The mission of the company is
extremely important.
You want to recruit,
retain those employees who share
the same mission.
And then you can focus on long-term
goal rather than just short-term
goal, right?
Also I learn a harder lesson.
Over the past several years,
I can tell you, our engineering
team very stable, I did not lose
a single top talents, but
we do lose a lot of salespeople.
Because they may not understand
the compensation, right?
That's why I see no folksong and
recruiting those talents.
Okay, share the same mission focus
on long term.
Immediate is such a good example.
So >> I'm sorry I was on mute.
>> [LAUGH] [APPLAUSE] That's
the best feature,
>> [LAUGH] >> For Zoom.
>> So Eric, my name is Shantel.
MBA one as well.
My question to you is,
your Zoom really transformed within
the first three to six months.
I went from talking to my
grandfather's forehead to actually
hosting thousands of people on it
and you said customer was in
the center of your development, but
you also had so
many different types of customers.
Customers wanting sophistication of
the product.
>> Yep. >> And others wanting
more basic needs.
So how do you optimize for
the product development phase and
the growth phase and
the communication phase of your
product ad.
>> Yes, good question.
So, as time goes on, right, so
the founder assumed the role you'll
have to change dynamic, right?
So for the first several years, I
was heads down to product side for
the first point of four, four and
a half a year, five years.
>> And after that I probably
saved most of my authority or
work to go to market and
as sales and marketing.
But later on I realized that's
not a scalable, we have to kind of
take their turn right and
a sort of a company that focus
apart from product focus to go to
market folks.
And as in back to the product
focus, I needed to shift the micro
to focus on product, that's what
had happened over the past six or
nine months right?
You have to make sure from the top,
right from a CEO perspective I
always.
>> Look at the product side
otherwise we're assuming that your
product may not be best right?
So that's why I dedicate a lot of
our go to market the responsibility
that the task was to other leaders
and spend most of time on
the product side.
And the lag is key features and
designs.
Sometimes the features using
very good for enterprise customers
may not work for consumers and
vice versa, all right?
By how to balance that.
Make sure you always simplify
the product experience.
And also make sure every product
managers, engineers,
they work they truly understand why
you added the feature.
Not when you build the,
product is very easy to edit so
many features.
>> But guess what,
it's not very easy to use anymore
is so crowded, right.
So how to balance that the ease of
use and a feature set in diverse
customers and also consumers,
right.
The case make sure you got to focus
part of that studying from the CEO
and a founder and all the team and
will fall.
>> Eric, thank you for sharing
those insights, and thank you for
all of your excellent questions.
>> [APPLAUSE] But
before I click end meeting,
it's a view from the top tradition
to close with a lightning round.
So I'll say a short statement and
you answer with the first thing
that comes into your head.
Ready? >> Yeah.
Always ready.
>> Most annoying Zoom habits, mute.
>> [LAUGH] >> Favorite
basketball team?
>> Warriors for sure, so yeah.
>> Got some fans.
Number of Zoom weddings you've
attended?
>> More than a dozen.
>> [LAUGH] >> Well if you're
looking for any more, I have quite
a few friends getting married this
year, so we can, >> I can do,
the wedding ceremony host on Zoom.
That's the best use case.
>> [LAUGH] >> .
Cause you even do know,
you need to put more make up.
Zoom has a very cool feature called
catch up your appearance.
Right?
>> [LAUGH] So,
I'll keep that in mind.
Best advice you've ever received
from your parents.
>> How to work and to be humble.
>> And something you can't
live without?
>> Love.
>> And I think the world that we
live in today that's something that
we could all use a bit more of.
Eric, thank you.
It's been a privilege.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]